- Un calme inhabituel dans
cette école de Lviv.
Sur le tableau, la date
du 23 février est toujours
inscrite. Le lende
l'invasion russe a forcé
les enfants à rester à la maison
pour suivre les cours en ligne.
Mais, il reste quelques
écoliers. Des enfants déplacés
par la gtrouvé refuge
dans cette école, comme Mariia,
qui non seulement apprend
ses leçons, mais mns, mais mns,e
et dort aussi entre ces murs.
"Je m'ennuie de mes camarades,
de mon enseignante,
de mes grands-parents et
de mon école", nous dit-elle.
"Quand  "Quand  "Quand  "Quand,
je retournerai immédiatement
à Kiev", nous explique-t-elle.
Mais l'école en ligne n'estpas.
Cette travailleuse sociale
accompagne David et Anatoliy
dans leur cheminement.
"Ils réussissent tous les
exercices, mais parfois,
ils sont désorientés",
raconte-t-elle.
La guerre a chamboulé la jeune
vie de ses enfants déplacés,
mais ils en parlent peu.
Un psychologue travaille
avec eux. C'est par le dessin
que les enfants expriment
leurs émotions.
Une manière de rester
au fait de leur état d'esprit
parce qu'ici, les rappels
de la guerre sont constants.
(sirène d'alarme)
Aujourd'est pas
la cloche qui marque la fin
des cours.
Encore une fois, une sirène
d'alarme.
Les enfants connaissent par
coeur le chemin jusqu'à l'abri.
Une fois tous réunis au sous-
ame Matys ame Matys ame Matys ae
de réconforter les petits.
La directrice est le pilier
de cette école devenue un refuge
pour la trentaine d'enfants
et leur famille. Elle veille à
tout, même aux vêtements pour
les écoliers.
Elle nous raconte que cette
fillette n'avait rien quand
arrivée avec son père.
(chant en ukrainien)
Ici tout le personnel
met l'épaule à la roue. L'enseie
chante des berceuses.
D'autres enseignants cuisinent
trois repas par jour.
Les journées sont longues,
les nuits sont courtes.
La jeune Mariia, elle, ne peut
s'empêcher de penser au moment
où elle va retourner chez elle.
"Tout va bien se terminer,
nous allons rentrer à Kiev,
et ce Poutine, conclut-elle,
il va mourir."
Des mots durs dans la bouche
d'une enfant, un écho de
la dureté de la guerre.
Et pour atténuer un peu
les bouleversements dans la vie
de ces écoliers, Mme Matys leur
offre toute sa chaleur humaine.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Lvi